I want to start by saying how much I
loved the movie it's great
I think everyone's gonna love this one
I'm sure you're hearing that from
everyone walking through ah I haven't
heard a bad review yet so I have to say
your character is so expanded in this
movie when did you sort of find out oh
my god this is gonna be I i'm the huge
part of this movie when i saw it about a
month ago you know i mean i i got an
inkling but i never you never know
because you know they edit things and it
was like it seemed that i had a
significant part and then when i saw it
was like holy smoke wow that's kind of a
big deal what i know that in this one
you recorded with tom had you done that
on the previous ones know that it's not
usually done but i think that they they
I mean the the filmmakers came up with
it and I think that they thought because
of the nature of our relationship and
this that especially with the romantic
stuff and everything and some of the
more emotional scenes that it would be
really best practices to get us together
like actors well I'm always surprised
that more animated films don't bring
people together did you find after
making the others that this sort of was
I guess you could describe a little bit
about the benefit of going together well
I think you know there's a synergy when
actors are in the room with each other
but of course they get these these I
mean it's Tim Allen and Tom Hanks and
Keanu Reeves and uh you know these
people have very busy schedules so I
would imagine like to get everybody
together even for a read-through would
be almost impossible so just you know
logistically speaking I think it would
be difficult but I mean
in in terms of well it recording
everybody separately doesn't seem to
have hurt any of the other films it's
but I do think that there there is an
advantage and it seems like ours that we
were together and it was certainly a lot
of fun I can only imagine one of the
things that I find fascinating about the
animated process is that what you start
making could be a radically different
movie by the end and yes
so I'm curious if you remember while
making this was there any sort of big
changes that happened that you remember
recording or was it pretty much the
journey you know what I mean well it
just kept evolving you know they're a
very I mean they're their creativity is
so alive it's so bubbling and changeable
and transformative and they you know
they start to render things and then
things happen and the people who are
developing these on their computers and
I mean all kinds of stuff happens so and
I worked on this for four years so I
mean that's a big sweep to just kind of
hold things in your mind so it would at
every time I came in of course lots of
other things would be developed and they
give me like a quick update and honestly
I kind of lost the thread and so your
Etsy is just total surrender to the
filmmakers which is great it's
surrenders good I got to stop there
congratulations movies fantastic thank
thank you so much for your time